[Musique]
une jupe autant entraîner une autre
alors que le rapport the vivi a été
exclue de l'émission the voice en raison
de plusieurs puits de polémiques posté
sur twitter lorsqu'il était adolescent
voilà qu'il prive aujourd'hui une autre
artiste de sa prestation vianney avait
opposé cerea de vivies de v vi avait
remporté sa bataille mais depuis il me
fait plus partie de la compétition
en effet puisque tf1 a décidé de
l'exclure de son programme sa prestation
lors des battles face à la chanteuse
série candidate de l'émission a été
coupée au montage situations délicates
comme ces battles ont été enregistrés
que série a été éliminé par de vivies la
jeune femme disparaît donc du programme
elle aussi sans que sa dernière
prestation et peut être diffusé à pau
difficile pour la jeune femme
je vis a décidé quant à lui de rendre
hommage à la chanteuse sur les réseaux à
l'occasion de cette battle j'ai gagné ce
qui fait en sorte que série n'apparaît
plus sur les écrans par ma faute
à cause de l'exclusion allait lui donner
un maximum de force s'il vous plaît
série a aussi pris la parole sur son
compte instagram en rassurant ses fans
comme il ya toujours du positif à tirer
de chaque situation
sachez que je reviendrai sur le plateau
de the voice pour interpréter la chanson
des battles en solo une façon de dire
pour pouvoir dignement
rendez vous donc dans les prochaines
diffusions
alors c'est quand même un choix de
production particuliers eux oui
christopher alors ils s'en sont bien
sortis pour le montage malheureusement
c'est à défaut avec la candidate qui
était face à lui mais il n'avait pas
d'autre choix avec le cas mais neil ça l
était il est et où il est obligé de
mettre dehors parce que ça c'est apparu
il aurait pu faire passer puisqu'il a
été éliminé
gardez la concurrence oui mais oui mais
sa toute dernière en date ayant mais
voilà éliminé donc finalement la
production va repêcher c'est ça le tout
dernier éliminé par des vis pour les
pour les live et en plus c'est très bien
parce que la production à la fin va la
vap les sept candidates pour qu'elle
chante qu'elle fasse le numéro qu'elle
avait fait qu'il était donc c'est bien
coûter sa place dans l'émission elle
avait perdu face à ce vide lors de la
battle donc voilà l'allemand s'était
vite fait quand même si vous trichez
dans un amendement au sport et que vous
êtes disqualifié c'est le deuxième de
ses fans n'avaient pas beaucoup de
solutions vous n'avez pas floutés la
prestation de sa vie avec l'autre
participantes qui était à cheval en quoi
et pourquoi par exemple n'avait pas
trente mille sont alors sont dans les
clous l'a carrément est surnommée camp
donné que je pense
vraiment
[Applaudissements]